My name is
Madea condo. Call me. Call me. Call Mine.
Yes,
I am a Japanese old amazing consultant.
I usually visit
the home and you haul
one to one organizing.
Listen,
there's a mean on this.
Gated the mall and let
us know cause I'm a no.
So first of all, let me start, um,
how I usually work with my clients.
Ah,
so this is the first example.
Yes.
Come on.
Do I need your name and just say this?
So she is the lady who lives in this room.
She is in the uh,
in her 20s.
[inaudible] I'm a big,
they bit the look there anymore.
You cannot stand him up one over here.
You already see in this picture that
she has full of stuff on my bed.
Actually that's actually of bat. But
you might not see it. And she also,
how a lot of stuff on the floor.
It, C'mon [inaudible] they thought
of the day, all they see on it.
And she first told me that, don't you
think the bedroom is just like a storage?
They can Nigel die this time.
So when she comes home after work,
she never ever feel relaxing in her room.
But
Holly Ball,
I'll stop my lesson.
It does look so neat and clean.
Of course,
nothing is on the floor.
Okay?
Tonto,
Zuni easier to look at the mouth.
So, uh, my job is to consult
how to organize. And Amit, I,
I've been doing this job
for more than 10 years.
Okay.
Characteristics or [inaudible] it's,
that's my client.
Never go back to the mess
because they have been transformative
to the [inaudible] person.
Today I going to tell you
how to make a hawk,
have to make your house.
He ordered Ela.
That's when you change your life forever.
It's a booster
post
about the snow. Mistletoe. No, Katie.
So before I start telling
you what to do, let me, um,
let me tell you how I start my job,
how I discovered this method.
Okay,
well let's take a look at
those again. You told me this,
I was only five years old when I got very
interested in how to organize things.
So let's look you gotta [inaudible] data
it organizing Duchesnay it home
[inaudible] and the [inaudible].
So I was already a picking
up every single issue. Oh,
the magazine that my mother
was subscribing and the
magazine was about how to
organize the house.
Well,
let's take a home cook the Turkey days.
So when I turned 15 years old,
I start at a serious consultation to
how to organize things if he posey
stereo digits
hasn't been time.
There was a best seller book in Japan.
Title,
how to add the, a technique to
technique to get rid of things.
And I read that book and I
discovered the method, the cut.
Those are going to get good data.
Nine
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so you probably wouldn't,
uh, you would probably wonder what I
started, how I started researching,
organizing things.
First I started weeding every single book,
publishing Japan on organizing at the Wa
[inaudible] and I also keep organizing
thing. I worked every single
day organizing things today,
my own Dube next day,
my brothas room,
Nick's the date next to the next two day.
My sister's room for
all the by the kitchen,
living room, bathroom, my friend's
room, friends, room, friends room,
my classmate, classroom, classroom,
classroom or with a [inaudible] and again,
be down to my own
mine.
It's got a Mustang.
So I spend most of my teenage years
organizing things just like that.
Let's see
this.
And I started organizing,
organizing consultant
consultation business when I
was 19 plus the [inaudible]
Hidatsa King Sweetie. I also picked
this topic in my thesis at College.
It's this your,
you look at it so safe to assume that
I am la crazy hiding part,
not the
budget base.
So you,
you were perfect to think that I'm
a fanatic organizer at this point.
Yes.
They look at their
whole kill up [inaudible] or site.
So I'd like to present Calmeri method,
which I discovered to
everybody here today,
Heidi Musto. So let me start
called mighty missile to one.
So number one of come Mary Method Heidi
in one shot as quickly as possible.
Okay.
Kayla [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] if you think you have to tidy
around you every day,
gradually, little by little,
that's completely wrong.
Nothing that up.
Mostly Anna de [inaudible]
Marico Tokai the small shop cook.
I say you still got this because you
need a shock that change your mind into
tidying your thing.
I rotate the tongue.
So you want to finish it in
very short period of time. Oh,
the muscle it's about has made guys number
cause you to go to this.
So the first important thing is
to set the deadline of organizing.
No,
it's [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] can we can,
okay.
This of course you can sit
the deadline in one week.
Assuming that you're going to do that
every day or you decide to do every
weekend and set the,
set the deadline in three months
as it,
what's it
[inaudible] muscle?
How does a killer Matsiti
special event nowadays?
So don't think about tiding is
everyday event. It's a special event.
Just like a festival.
It's about dies in Ecuador.
It's one of the iPhone eight has him.
He made him, you might want to say no,
you know,
call me Miss [inaudible] name.
So the number one number two item and
can marry method is how are you going to
do it?
Okay.
Fault by category,
not by location.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] today's,
it's very common to make this mistake.
If you try to organize things
in a specific location,
it's like [inaudible], [inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible] [inaudible]
it's short.
It never ends.
If you try to tidy up and just one portion
of the closet or one portion of the
living room.
[inaudible] mono category e catastrophe.
Take play a couple of these.
The right way to do is to organize
by category and do it quickly.
It's my little daughter though.
What's your
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Yoga
cods well, for example, if you decide
to organize your clothes first,
take out all of the clothes
in your house in one spot.
Make a big pile of all of the
clothes you have in newer house. Dot.
Kale.
Yes. Your yet. Anatta
No. Who slipped it dusty.
It doesn't yet. Smitty
[inaudible] then. No.
Yes. So it just, in the same way, if
you decide to organize your books,
take out all your books from your bookcase
and pile them up in one location in
there, in the house. I, he's
will they sit with me? Both the,
I still thought, I know. It looks hard.
It's really messy.
I'll tell you why you need to do this.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] they'll know.
Maybe that's comical.
If you bring out all your stuff,
books,
clothes in one location,
you visually realize how much books,
how much clothes, how many closes,
how many books you have.
Well, that's, that's what
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
on a daily life. We rarely understand
how much stuff we have around us.
Hey,
the wall called [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] get d'amico.
Nominal book pushed seal number. No. Oh,
okay.
This,
so it is a great opportunity if you
bring out everything in one spot,
we allies how much stuff you have,
how many books do you have so that you
can decide which one you want to keep,
which one you really need to keep,
and which way you can get rid of.
Talk to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
So from,
from this point,
the next step you have to take
is to sort them, you know,
separate them,
separate them between your nest ad that
thinks you need and things you don't.
And the criteria of this method cracked.
The criteria I recommend in my
method is a little bit unique.
So de la [inaudible],
that's number three.
[inaudible] method.
Septic shock.
Does it spark joy
cookie Nikki spark joy this.
So it's,
does it spark joy?
This is the keyword [inaudible] I know,
I definitely feel weird air in
this room right now. Don't worry.
I used to did the action of the ods.
That's it.
This is a really common
reaction in my seminar.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so what I mean by saying spark joy,
I can explain exactly what it is.
So if you look at one thing,
you should question yourself.
If that thing makes you happy
as a make you impressed,
it's a
sleep state in one on it,
on this man. Got To this.
If they,
although Arabic Dyson,
Anondi's Benny people
always think first what,
which one to get widow.
But it is much more important
to think which one to keep,
which one you want to keep and
lived together from now on.
Does so it's looking like come on.
No intimate point though.
They're not just saying oh slash mass.
So I will tell you that how to make it
the surgeon point the law come out as a
solo mono Salado Cotto so
point number one,
make sure you touch it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
take every single item you can
think of in your hand on your hand.
Well, no, well no, no.
And Imagine how your body
reacts to that moment. How you,
how you feel when you touch the touch.
The item
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
kind of like a door handle.
SUNOCO
spark joy.
So sparks Joey.
This is,
this is that we action from your body
that we action you feel from your body.
When you touched the item,
you should keep
cool. Now Helen, it's like that.
Even most hype
can't see this.
You feel everything single part of your
body faces up when you touch the item.
That's the right feeling.
Jacqueline [inaudible]
Dharma conceal certain Oka.
So on the other hand, if the item
doesn't give you any inspiration,
for example,
this one,
you start at feeling down
even though kind of squashed it.
Soccer.
Oh,
body stride at feeling down.
[inaudible]
quite a lot.
Am I mean that's hunger data issue.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I know you are skeptical,
but if you really tried to do this,
you realize how your body really reacts.
It's [inaudible] definitely
after the seminar
when you go home tonight.
Tried part of it.
Yeah.
Well that's in the Ho Ho Ho Ho,
isn't it?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
it's not mistletoe. This,
let me go over my three basic methods.
Do we quickly in short amount of time
and so by category and find the item if
the item sparks joy
ultimo [inaudible] life changing magic
of tiding up when [inaudible] mass at
mass. So this is my book, and if
you need to know more about it,
if you would like to know more about it,
please pick up this book.
Quit [inaudible] Miss [inaudible].
So I definitely want every
one of you two week my book,
but I will give you one more
technique.
Catholiccare no.
Tadashi Jen Baum this.
So this is the right order of organizing
you thought.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] boundaries.
There's definitely the right
order when you organize stuff,
and this is how it goes.
Stuff from clothes, books,
document miscellaneous items.
Then mementos.
Hello,
Jim bow.
Make sure you follow this order.
That's an on the scale of the mall.
And those was hashing this
[inaudible]
it's Jonathan couples.
Get,
am I saying it often happens when
you are going through old photos.
Oh, the mentors, the items
you were given from my mother.
It always stops you from organizing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that's why I definitely recommend you
this order because this order gives you
the sense of spark,
joy feeling.
You'd definitely learn that
feeling with your body.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible], [inaudible]
[inaudible] or nothing.
Okay.
So in this order,
while you start with close
your body and your mind,
get trained with spark, joy feeling. And,
but by the time you reach to mementos,
you're already good at how to do you
already know how to go through momentos.
Sure.
Or Teen Kaytra Chico state.
I'd like you to try my
method with this order.
Hopefully tonight.
This coal mine always
works.
I hope you
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I know
what the mass,
so I explain all my message
to you right now by now.
So I would like to open the floor
for Q and a session. Please.
Kinda tunnel.
Should we say thank you to Josh?
So there's two mikes.
There's one Mike over there and
there's one Mike over there.
If you'd like to line up,
um, I'll get it started.
Um,
just cause I'm right here.
So I wanted to know how do you
deal with somebody who has a child,
like a one year old child
and there's toys everywhere?
Hmm.
They buy [inaudible] advice.
I did initial,
yeah.
Well think the content is now,
well this isn't right.
Difficult. It depends on
the child's age. But, um,
I have two different methods
depending on the Child Age. The, uh,
the borderline is about three years old.
Did come up.
What are some on the Boeing,
you are on the mall or the
Bible or Carson [inaudible]
because if the child is
younger than three years old,
most of the cases parents just
organize their stuff. Yeah.
Stay. The more, not the eternal,
the Ariba Ocado is going to escape.
They're not, they didn't, isn't it?
But if the child is over two years old,
older than three years old,
it's time to train them how to organize
things and they're capable of it. Okay.
It's [inaudible] dot
com as it one more time.
[inaudible] day you'll.
Yes.
And the important thing at this point
is do not tell them to organize a toys.
Tell them to organize the clothes.
That's important.
[inaudible] oil.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
well,
I'll tell you why.
Because clothing is something
you always put on every day.
So if you learn how to fold the clothes
that you always put on and put it back
into the clothing, the right spot,
that's the best way that they learn.
We they need to organize and
importance of organizing things.
That's the point of this name.
So a number one key is to
teach then how to, how to,
how to fold the clothes.
Okay. Next question.
So I,
I understand your method in terms of
getting yourself into a mindset where you
only have to do this once,
but I was curious how you deal
with things that we acquire.
Either things that we acquire ourselves
or things like gifts that come in to the
house.
Do you do an inventory annually or do you
just not let them come into the house?
Wow,
look all
I know you didn't [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
these all say about this in
the bite mark at the nineties
you know, in her case she doesn't
really have any criteria, any order,
any rules for that,
those sticker
Ikea kitchen.
Because her method is completely
based on if you were impressed,
if you get inspired by the item.
Okay.
Oh
Steve Staiger
because it depends on the person,
how often you want to organize or how
much stuff you need to keep a wound
yourself.
Hello?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
because my method again and again, it's
based on if you get inspired, you know,
if you get,
you know,
at the sparks joy feeling that doesn't
really bring it back to the crowd were
cratering situation.
It's not really depending on how often
you should acquire or how you get the
stuff. Yeah. In your room.
Thank you. Thank you.
A question.
Hi. Thank you so much for coming. Um,
the question is I have a
lot of things that I need,
but I don't like what
they don't inspire joy.
How do I find the balance between
keeping versus discarding them?
I all [inaudible] morning.
Can you start? Well, you
on this card
for example,
what kind of like item g mat study books
and like very old kitchen utensils that
I haven't been please.
They do.
Oh God.
Ah, we'll see. Talk to me tonight.
We're still not there yet.
I'm not only,
I couldn't talk to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
is your name.
If you judge, those items are
necessary for you right now.
That means those items
to our making you happy.
Hold on.
This email,
we're still almost won the law.
Get someone to stop [inaudible] milk.
So even if you're not
inspired by those item items,
but if they are necessary to you
right now, you should keep them. Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
got it.
So when recommendation recommendation I
can give you is that if the item doesn't
inspire you, if you don't get
the special feeling, you know,
try to try to talk it into
it. Try, try to, you know,
convince it. Convince yourself
that this is a good thing.
This is a good thing for you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
keep doing it.
Even if the item doesn't inspire you,
you started getting
positive feeling about it.
MMM [inaudible]
so in this way, you probably find
all the items you have in your house.
Inspiring. I see. Thank you. I
was thinking, I was like, man,
next question.
Um, have you ever encountered
like in some of your clients,
uh, I think my question is basically
about there's shared spaces.
If you are sharing like a living
room or the kitchen with somebody,
maybe you want to keep it clean.
Are the things that are important for you?
Um,
I know that many,
but the things that are important
to the other person or they,
most of them and they're just all
over the place. So is there like, um,
a way to make it work? So I'm like dios
how your space like from this and how,
how does this,
okay. Can you, can you speak
up? I'm sorry, I didn't catch
the whole question. Okay.
Um,
I'm just curious about how to deal when,
how to deal with the case when most of
the stuff actually does not belong to you.
So it's not your decision to keep it
all hell. She had, I stayed at the
[inaudible] food by I
oh,
you up?
No. Are belonging to
someone else. Correct. Yep.
That's all sort of, the
muscle has made it. Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] isn't it?
You should prioritize to organize your
own items before you started thinking
about someone else.
[inaudible] they
go
[inaudible]
can I say from my experience,
you know,
in the past 10 plus years of my career,
um,
I've definitely seen a several
clients who keeps saying that, oh,
I tried to tidy up my brand,
but my husband does incorporate,
my kids don't relate corporate.
But if you look at clients saying
something like that, they're,
the women food are not
tedding up correctly.
They had lots of what you want.
Let just name
this is true de
[inaudible] Toyota
[inaudible] so I'm not sure.
No Basho so they're just on the space.
They are not [inaudible] Schmidt,
the committee smile [inaudible] candies.
I know you'll have to
organize stuff no matter what.
So the important thing is you organize
your strap and put them in newer space.
So separate the space with other people
so you take care of your stuff in your
space and leave the other stuff and
other spaces to the out of people.
Magical one. Obama didn't. Scott
[inaudible] [inaudible]
she didn't worry about this
space allocated to other
people because that's up to
them. That's their own business. How
do you use them? How to organize them?
Oh, what's wrong with
Donald? Hello? Hello, hello.
[inaudible]
of course you can set up rules. A few
rules like you shouldn't really, you know,
anything shouldn't leak out or you
know anything. She'd be exposed,
stuff like that.
But that's,
that's the best way to do without
the people think was that company.
Good luck.
Hi. Um, thank you for coming. I was,
since you talk here about how to initially
kind of purge the items you have,
just sorting into what to keep and not,
do you also have recommendations for then
how you go about organizing the items
that you decide to keep or do you
leave that up to the individual person
day?
Bye.
[inaudible] hello?
Hi. Yes, there is a clear rule.
What's it on?
The whole thing.
So make sure to organize the same
cat items in the same category.
In the same spot.
Did you sang?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
it's funny,
I often see at people's houses the same
I the items in the same category here
and there.
They're kind of scattered around.
So my point is to put all of
them together in one spot.
Okay.
[inaudible] guys,
it's not otherwise you'll
[inaudible]
yes. So as I showed you earlier, um,
organizing by category is very important
and another important things I can
definitely tell you is how to fold the
clothes. That's definitely a big key.
Great. Thank you. Thank you.
Hey, uh, thanks for coming here and thanks
for taking the time to write a book. Um,
I have a friend who, um, is, uh, you know,
pretty serious hoarder with
lots of stuff and uh, you know,
when you ask him, you know, do you need
this stuff? Can you throw this stuff away?
The answer is, Oh, I might
need it later. Or, you know,
I have this grand plan to
use this in such a way,
but of course that never happens and
you know, stuff just keep accumulating.
I wonder if you have worked with clients
like that and you know what you say to
them and you know what the outcome is.
Hm.
I know what the more that then a mom at
the mall at the day [inaudible] so we
stayed at [inaudible] Michelle,
that's the kid cannot otherwise
probably you were asking me the Fys
to somebody food don't even bother
organizing.
Okay.
No actually is pretty organized.
You know, he can find things.
He's just a huge amount of stuff that,
oh say it's not cluttered,
but he has a lot of items.
Is, is a lot of items and is
kind of creeping into day.
Cora. Dot. Space and so on.
You kind of walk around in the House
[inaudible]
not,
we'll see.
Um,
what's
[inaudible]
he is my client.
I don't think it's important for
me if he has too many items or not.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
they will do this.
I it is much,
much more important to figure out if
that person is happy with that amount of
items.
Well,
the [inaudible] what the sealer and Muslim
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so I would probably recommend that person
to imagine the ideal lifestyle for the
person.
Do you go out the Legal Nolan?
Could I say [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I think your friend need to figure out
what kind of lifestyle he or she wants.
You know, what kind of, uh,
what's the realistic life,
you know,
your friend wants so that he or she can
figure out how much stuff to keep or
what to keep, what not to keep, et cetera.
And this is very efficient
way of mindset for anybody.
If you would have somebody like that
in your family members, you know,
friends around you, this is really
highly recommend it. Okay. Thank you.
So we have time for one more question.
Those of you that were lucky enough
to get here early and got a book, uh,
Maria will sign them in the
back afterwards. Okay. Oh, neat.
Um, uh, yeah,
my question is related to something
that as engineers to be thinking that
sometimes a, be too much. That how
frequently some we should run this task.
They should have,
we done it in an online,
think about it all the joining all the
time. It should be done in a batch.
So what do you think about organizing?
What's the ideal
frequency that you advise?
Like should we think always be running in
our mind? Oh I just picked up a pen. Uh,
it's probably not that useful anymore.
So,
and should we always be thinking
about how should we do it?
Something like at the extreme
end would be like once in a year,
which is what I do typically like at
the end of the year in December I think.
All right,
let's,
this is a bag for goodwill does the bag
to throw and that's like the minimum
that would be due.
So what's when and when should we do that?
Like should we do it like end of the year
she will do the every end of the day.
I should be constantly be thinking about
every time we encounter thinking on how
Sarah at workplace.
Oh good.
I know him.
Thank
otherwise.
Is Kai dad about okay.
This, well Mike Answer is,
the only answer is just do it one time.
It's sad about Anulka Toyota.
It's the noisiest [inaudible]
the wall [inaudible]
talking about when you should do,
my answer is right now,
it can be any time. But who, wait now
if you cut that [inaudible] Mondays.
Well,
the reason is it's not
for tidying up your house,
tidying up your living space.
It's all about how you want to spend
the rest of your life from now on.
Let me, I'm all day.
No. [inaudible] awesome.
So my,
I highly recommend you
to do it right now asap.
Good luck.
Okay.
Any closing comments or anything else that
those
get hold to [inaudible]
I know the, uh, the topic is kind of
puzzling. It's very unusual, but um,
you know, as a conclusion, I
would like to tell you why the
crested I started.
So I know every one of
us has so many items.
There are so many items in our life,
but figuring out what items do you or
how right now is figuring out how you are
going to live your life.
It's like you're not listening.
So it
stage.
So my method is telling you to examine
every single item in New York life.
That means you will examine,
you,
assess your lifestyle and the life
you want to leave from. No one
no
that, no that, that Daca,
Daca.
So once you find out the inspiration
from every item you have,
you probably learned inspiration on how
you want to live, how you want to work,
how, how you want to
be succeeded, um, how,
how you want to make
friendship, et cetera. Come on.
I need to get the [inaudible].
So find out your own inspiration point
with item and with your lifestyle.
Oh, okay. Cool.
Sorry.
Am I see it?
Thank you for listening to
come marry method. And please,
please touch one each item you have
and feel the inspiration from them.
Thank you very much today.